good morning John it's how long I have
to take this hello hey yeah I really
don't like when you call me that's a
little uncomfortable yeah but I think
you can see how this is a little bit
weird when you call me like this yeah
but I can see their point I mean my
video was technically longer than four
minutes yeah it's it's frustrating I
didn't think that it was gonna be
punishable my video obviously ended
before for a minute I I know I agree
with you I mean it's not like John
didn't have a pretty fantastic day that
he decides to punish me while he's
having like the best day of his life
oh you haven't heard about this oh this
is probably going to make you even more
angry John found out today that he's
gonna debut in the New York Times
bestseller list for young adult fiction
at number 5 yeah yeah dude you should be
happy for him he's your brother you
helped him do that well yeah I mean we
helped him do that and now we're getting
punished but but that's not the point in
the nerdfighters who helped him do it
it's not you he wasn't you shut up it
was the nerdfighters it wasn't you first
of all it was me it wasn't this evil
Hank on the phone second of all it was
the nerdfighters oh dude I'm tired of
you speaking you with a warm tongue crap
into my ear I'm hanging up on you bye
goodbye goodbye what a jerk
John Green New York Todd to John Green
John Green near 10th Essex hello Arthur
and Paper Towns John Green the New York
Times best-selling book Paper Towns
best-selling author John Green the New
York Times best selling author John
Green my brother
New York Times best seller I really
don't think he ever thought that that
would happen to him and now it totally
did and paper sounds so deserves to be
bestseller and I'm so excited that it is
I mean John was really very scared about
this and it has absolutely blown away
his expectations he is the happiest man
on the planet I just talked to him he
was in Florida at a nerdfighter event
and he said that the atmosphere was
absolutely fantastic and everyone was
just loving everyone and it was so much
fun and my best friend from high school
was there and John's best friends from
elementary school were there and it was
just a phenomenal day and John I can't
wait to hear about it in your video
tomorrow
as for me I'm moving and this isn't my
punishment but I am going to be
participating in the Ironman Bob CD
challenge tomorrow starting at 3 p.m.
Eastern 1 p.m. mountain time I will be
staying up for as long as I can without
caffeine everyone else is gonna be using
caffeine but I'm going substance-free on
this one with the likes of Shay Carl and
Charles Trippy lots of other of my
YouTube peers we're gonna stay up as
long as we can and the winner is the
person who can stay up longest I'm
pretty sure I'm going to lose but I'm
going to try my darndest
I'm gonna be about to you starting at 3
and until perpetuity for a long time so
if you would like to come see me and see
what I'm doing during that very long
time please do with the link is in the
sidebar everyone leave your punishment
suggestions in the comments New Times
bestselling author Paper Towns jump read
now I will see you tomorrow